у
зараз у чині тема інформація дитину не
лише з найманка з поняттям
інформація то замість нового для і
початкового предмета та виявляючи з ночі
в кабінеті прилад для роботи з
інформації в 4-го жив його ви означає і на
еблище коли розвитку дітей даного
класу ви його ти начальнику треби учень
ваги воші в бесідах
revo їх обов'язки випробувань і до тета
засіка ленності зданого на премію
задування про органи для spree манія
інформації називання organic трохи а то й
гриз ви вдома інформатики називаються за
ніжності крученого як їм органом з прямо
йому то трохи розширити у я ваня
за інформацією підготую роботу їду ви
вчення про цю bespeco у світі ж і
розмежування приватний
то публічної інформації та лиж вона
приклади доступні дітям можливим
викури станемо з і але ними на пояс
найнятих слив особиста знаю вище
секретно інформація лиша для батьківщини
приклад у кожну із сім'ї і така
інформація ще й не за видами ля
їм, наприклад, в інтернеті з банківських
карт до домашньої адреси номер мобільного
телефону
таку інформацію називають приватну
обоссу б стою а на фото своїх тварин
свої малюнки з радістю диман будувати у
цьому світлі ти за вона доступна обидва
публічної інформації або за видами ляють
навіки незнайомців на прикладних
розлітаються та живлення захисту приватної
інформації забезпеченого б каристом вони і
які з влади вистій інформації
достовірність помотати синій своїй годині
не відразу велися до стоп неквапливість
прибираючи в читай сам остину для
організації їх товари дня
жеки в їх прикладі правило достатньо і
по wedding та в кабінеті зазвучав
вручаються по-старшому практичну роботу
і dtn і за комп'ютером у чверть сам би
означає зикову уроку почитай про
а ти за комп'ютером і алея нічого ночі
з іншого урок піде і кожному уроці
математиком п'ють ерни практикам
використання домашніх пристроїв на
уроках інформатики через діод не
спеціального кабінету вимагає готельна
підготовкою до всього в 4 до
адміністратора початкового закладу
обирали
обговорить і принесуть, наприклад, планшети
травня but i проте в апараті на систему
для всіх пристроїв ще знач нас про стати
роботу в читали у синаї об'єднаного
що ваня для повноцінної роботи дитини
а їхні зуби ти бочки розум враховуємо
наприклад на батицьких зборах про і нато
сяду готові marriage це запам'ятає від неї
завантажити на спідниці дні для уроки
додатки на ваш туго ти рудим без пкм
тягнучи на великих уроках у крем виявлення
початкових потреб вчинивши в чотири
значення гривень шкірного вчиняючи якраз
дві години приватними пристроєм та
c краще рубає на гру викл їх до них
правах далі в роті вибрати ще у
класно ти один раз виявляться мишка
злити думав це з вивченням ще до
терміни я хочу ви плану і ти куриш
хапайся тачскріном читати подам слова
класно тобто. треба сич коректним було на
планшетах сенсорних екранах ми не
клацаєм і щільність араби модель легкої
до також вибрати ще сабів коза ти там і
універсальні слова ви брат і взуття
ти можеш ніби кристина поміти
застарілого клас над 1 раз лівою
кнопкою мишки ви у чаї ніж маніпулятори
краще у понго ти використання ігор після
давно в мене піруватий air вухом і курсором
спочатку в меню вибору тягнуся в коза ти
труби таг їх до dota по тачпаду погода
зовсім не класно ти мене відкрита
запуску цієї програми навик вона не
з просунувся dota cpu тачпад і вище
станемо мене переміщати об'єкти
якщо ти з формованих навідників можна за
пропана вати дітям роботу та свекор та
станемо клавіатури
я провела pm накидки з дітей нікулін та
проц і вал з мишку та сенсорним екраном
та touchpad на ноутбуці
вибуху старших уроки ви його ти таких
дітей до одягаєте і мусабаєва Петро ім
канат на дільничному етапі він і швидко
навчаться щурів туго тася маніпулятором і
аллен і в пам'яті свої тут гостях
вас google і немає липові але про цю
дати ну на тлі белль 6 ендже хакі
нехай і ну переставити я вже всіма за
комп'ютером невинні тижні хуч ньому
вже буде і викладка на не звучному для
їх розміщенням маніпулятори
клавіатури свічка працювати сенсорним
екраном неудобно посадка ми бли ми ще
на вигляд поїдають віковими особливостями гейко
перші уроки в дет отримувати йому до
нових умов навчання до нових пристроїв
за ким і їм доводитися протитум продавши
широкому там утащі ігри для розвитку
новачок роботи з маніпулятором це ви
його не початкових потреб дітей моїх
бутану прочитає вежа їм це за коплі
шинки